[Music]
the hunt is a community that provides
styling recommendations and advice to
each other one member of the hunt could
be asking the question of what should I
wear and another member of the hunt is
answering that question by providing
products style recommendations advice
and so forth the community is now more
productive it's working better than ever
before and this is due to the success of
our Android material design was a great
way to start building the Android app it
was like having a team of design experts
helping you build the best product for
an Android device it allowed us to
simplify a lot of the things that we
were trying to tackle early on it's an
excellent structure which allowed us to
just focus on what was important for our
users the floating action button was
actually really intuitive to our users
we use it for starting a hunt and adding
a find or two main actions and we've
tested it with our beta testers and they
just got it
on Android with the Play Store we were
able to iterate as fast as we do with
our web app today and we can push our
production app to our user base every
day that's not possible in other mobile
platforms if we were to do it again I
would definitely go after Android first
the results that the most compelling to
me are we had about 15 percent of our
weekly users starting hunts now on
Android in particular with material
design it's increased to 20% of our
Android user base so we're seeing
150,000 hunt started a week and our
Android community has increased their
participation on hunt solving from 10%
of our weekly users to 15% the
conversation around what to buy is not
happening on content sites it's not
happening on social media sites it's
happening in these social commerce sites
like the huntin more and more retailers
and brands are joining the hunt and
they're providing style recommendations
to our community by having their team's
solve hunts it doesn't feel like it's
marketing it doesn't feel commercial
doesn't feel like advertising because
they're really engaging in a
conversation with their community we
believe that as we go international as
we scale our user base to tens of
millions of community members that the
hunt on Android will be our platform to
make this happen